[ Cheers and applause ]
Please welcome, Ray Wimley,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yeah. What? Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, yeah.
-Ray Wimley.
Ray, welcome to the show.
This is fun to run into a guy
like that on the street.
-Oh, likewise. I felt that.
It was crazy.
-Yeah.
-Flabbergasted.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-And then it went viral.
Did your life just change?
-Yeah.
I thought it was gonna be
a lot of people outside my house
after it was over with,
but that ain't happened yet.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no.
There's always tomorrow.
[ Laughter ]
Here's how this works.
I'm going hit this button here,
and it's gonna activate
a random word generator.
It will land on
three random words.
And it is your job to work them
into a freestyle rap together.
You ready for this?
-Yeah.
-Alright. Grab the mic there.
-And again, these are words
that our writers made up.
So this is gonna be
some fun things.
These are stuff that you
probably
normally wouldn't rap about.
Here you go.
[ Laughter ]
Here are the words.
Here we go.
[ Beeping ]
[ Laughter ]
Oh, yeah! Alright!
Good luck.
Cookie dough, kitchen skink,
and hot curl summer.
[ Laughter ]
That's okay? You good?
Any questions?
You got this?
Alright, here we go.
Roots, can we get
a beat on this?
-1, 2, 3.
-♪ [ Rapping ] Yo, I'm never
playin' rookie ♪
♪ Went to the kitchen,
I had to get a cookie ♪
♪ But they said, "Oh, no.
Yo, you gotta flow ♪
♪ If you gettin' money, you got
that cookie dough, oh ♪
-♪ And that dough, we need it ♪
♪ I know it's kinda hard ♪
♪ when you goin' through them
hot summer days ♪
♪ And you feel defeated ♪
♪ I'm lookin' at my mama ♪
♪ She on that kitchen sink ♪
♪ Washin' dishes
for them collard greens ♪
♪ Oh, this how we think ♪
-♪ This is how we think ♪
♪ Common sense gettin' under ♪
♪ See these hot girls --
hot girls this summer ♪
♪ And, yo, I gotta wonder ♪
♪ I gotta wonder why that boy
like that boy or that girl ♪
♪ Crispy summer ♪
♪ Honest ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoo!
-Yes! How do you do it?
-I get, uh...
Should we try one more?
-Yeah.
-Alright, this one's gonna be
a little bit harder, okay?
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
[ Beeping ]
-Oh.
You goin' first.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, okay. Wait.
"You go first."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you go first.
-Wi-Fi password, portrait mode,
is that --
is on your phone --
you can put it in portrait mode
for a nicer picture.
[ Laughter ]
Wi-Fi password.
This is something --
I could do this in two seconds.
[ Audience groans ]
I don't have a mic.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
[ Mid-tempo funk music plays ]
♪♪
-Try your best.
-Why is that my beat?
Why is my beat like that?
[ Rapping ] ♪ 'Cause every time
I rap like a nerd ♪
♪ I go to my girlfriend ♪
♪ "You're watching
Wi-Fi password" ♪
♪ Can I steal it?
Can I get it quick? ♪
♪ 'Cause I got to watch
this show on Netflix ♪
Okay.
-♪ On Netflix, we watchin' ♪
♪ We ain't got the Roots, yo,
you know there's no stoppin' ♪
♪ They say that girl, yo,
that girl look cold ♪
♪ If we take a picture, we
put it in portrait mode ♪
♪ And she know what happen ♪
♪ Yo, she lookin' good ♪
♪ She understood ♪
♪ She was comin'
from that hood ♪
♪ And I am just sayin'
I got a whole plan ♪
♪ To the right is my man ♪
♪ His name is ray ♪
-♪ My name is Ray ♪
♪ Man, I'm havin' fun all day ♪
♪ And I like the sound ♪
♪ It's like a marching band,
wow ♪
♪ Lookin' so nice,
it's so tight ♪
♪ I'm lookin' at these lights ♪
♪ Man, I think
the show is cool ♪
♪ Let's have some fun tonight ♪
♪ So, what we doin'? ♪
- ♪ Havin' fun tonight,
keep showin' ♪
♪ Let's keep on flowin' ♪
♪ This style is growin' ♪
♪ This is what we do
when we freestyle ♪
♪ Right now, we goin',
"Tonight Show" crowd ♪
-♪ He got a pink shirt on ♪
-♪ Wing shirt on,
it's kinda pink ♪
♪ I'm seein' what I'm sayin',
what I think, yo ♪
♪ We got a link, yo,
we puttin' it in sync ♪
♪ When it come to pink,
you lookin' fresh ♪
♪ Nah, they stink ♪
♪ Ah, she got the white shirt ♪
-♪ How you doin',
Mrs. White Shirt? ♪
♪ She be on the front aisle ♪
♪ They pullin' as
they like the freestyle ♪
♪ And I'm lookin'
at her toe nails ♪
♪ They white, to,
and it's lookin' nice ♪
♪ Ooh, this is what we doin' ♪
♪ Havin' fun as y'all clappin' ♪
♪ As we walkin'
up these stairs ♪
♪ This is why
we get to rap here ♪
♪ How you doin', man? ♪
♪ She be coolin' with the parlor
when she laughin' ♪
♪ And she got the cap,
and she lookin' nasty ♪
-♪ Come on, she lookin' at you
'cause you sorta handsome ♪
♪ Common sense, I took
this style for ransom ♪
♪ It's like this -- these size
I keep spillin' it ♪
♪ She want him has buckin',
we called him Gilligan ♪
♪ That's when it happened,
we was on an island ♪
♪ Now we on Jimmy Fallon,
and we freestylin' ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
Give it up for Common
and Ray Wimley!